on est face à un nouvel environnement
que toutes les oeuvres ont le droit de
vivre qu'elles vont trouver leur place à
tel ou tel endroit
moi je rappelle aussi que les
plateformes aujourd'hui et on a beaucoup
parlé de s vod donc les plateformes par
abonnement mais les plates formes à
l'acte ou permettent aussi de découvrir
des catalogues qui malheureusement ne se
trouve pas forcément en dvd puisque je
rappelle que le dvd aujourd'hui est un
support en grande souffrance qu'on ne va
pas forcément retrouver dans des cycles
de festivals ou de cinéma cartier de
cinéma d'art et essai et donc la serène
dépité un sérieux le fait de rentrer
dans une plate forme de vidéo à la
demande et de pouvoir balayer les
catalogues de les visiter de chez soi
alors certes dans un espèce de
confinement d'écran ça c'est sûr mais ça
permet aussi de découvrir et de parfaire
sa culture cinématographique
je rappelle aujourd'hui que mon nombre
de films de catalogue sont accessibles à
des prix très modeste et ça permet aussi
aux jeunes à ces fameux jeunes dont on
parlait tout à l'heure de découvrir des
réalisateurs qu'on ne voit pas la
télévision puisque je rappelle que la
télévision au dessus a fait son travail
sur on va dire le travail de sape autour
du cinéma on voit de moins en moins de
films sur les chaînes de télévision tous
les cas aux heures de grande écoute et
donc les plateformes sont en train de
remplacer cet espace où on peut plus
aller traîner chez un vendeur de dvd je
rappelle que tous les vidéo clubs ont
quasiment fermé et donc si on veut
approfondir sa connaissance
cinématographique les plateformes
aujourd'hui peuvent rendre ce service et
c'est pour ça que il faut les laisser
grandir et et répondre aux besoins et
aux attentes du public
[Musique]